more women are sharing their personal
experiences with early pregnancy loss
the American College of Obstetricians
auditions yeah and Gynecologists there
you go
estimates about one in ten pregnancies
you tried at home he won't be able to
say it out if Beyonce Michelle Obama
Carrie Underwood and recently Meghan
McCain all spoke publicly about their
miscarriages in hopes of breaking the
culture of silence traffic anchor Jamie
Stelter of New York won a 24-hour news
channel that we know well here in New
York City shared her fertility struggles
on social media and live TV Stelter
reveals she it has five miscarriage whoa
five miscarriages while trying to
conceive in an op-ed for Glamour
magazine she writes this the sting of
all the loss in the trauma phase for
sure but it never goes away I wear these
losses like scars they each have their
own story to tell with dates and numbers
and wait times but how can you possibly
quantify them
you can't Stelter has a two-year-old
daughter her name is sunny and she's due
to have another baby yeah in two weeks
she joins us now with our doctor Tara
and Narula to discuss I think welcome to
you both Bravo to you Jamie for telling
the story you tell it in such detail and
it's so pointed so painful but at the
same time so powerful and I like what
you said about every woman has a story
by the numbers help us understand your
numbers story when it comes to this well
it wasn't until I had miscarriages and I
started going through fertility
treatments that I realized there was
this giant Club of women who were all
speaking in their own language in terms
of how many miscarriages and then
there's all of the how long until you
have to wait until you get your period
again after a miscarriage how long is a
pregnancy and as soon as you get
pregnant you're thinking to yourself
okay I'm having a baby in 40 weeks from
now yeah and then when you have a
miscarriage you have to sort of quote
start over and it's very overwhelming
when you think about these numbers on a
day-to-day basis and you're trying to
wrap your head around it and you're
grieving at the same time and then
you're also trying to live your normal
life at the same time many people in
your life may not even know that you
were pregnant so a lot of the suffering
a lot of the grieving is happening
in private well we're in a culture where
you're taught to not talk about your
pregnancy until the three-month mark
so most miscarriages happen in those
first three months so if you never told
people you were pregnant you're surely
not going to march around and tell
people that you had a miscarriage yes
yeah it's re miscarriage is so common
and yet many women suffer in silence
which is heartbreaking to learn why is
there still a stigma
well yeah first of all I want to thank
Jamie and all the other one who opened
up because they're going to break down
the stigma it's that vulnerability and
honesty that's gonna bring empathy and
understanding and support which is
really what we need I think the stigma
is multifactorial you know as women so
much of our sense of self is tied into
motherhood and fertility and when we
lose a child the feeling is I somehow
lost it I failed there's something wrong
with me or my body and there's a
tremendous amount of shame and guilt and
we tend to insulate and not share that I
think what Jamie mentioned also which is
we're told culturally don't talk about
your pregnancy until the end of the
first trimester means that when we lose
the baby there's not that outpouring of
community support to give us love and
embrace us also when you lose someone a
parent or a friend we market in our
culture with rituals with ceremonies
religious rites we don't have anything
like that when it comes from miscarriage
but that invisible loss there's the same
sense of profound grief and trauma that
there is with any other kind of law I
thought it was interesting Jamie that
you wrote you would think having Sonny
and I see you were a necklace it says
Sonny you would think having Sonny would
make it easier for you but in many
respects it made it harder for you to go
through this it did because first of all
you see how beautiful having a child is
and you see that it can work so when I
had two miscarriages between Sonny and
this healthy pregnancy it's why can't my
body do this again knowing you might
talk about women do you talk about women
who have a baby and you think why are
they why are they trying to have another
one they at least have one and I don't
even have one to be you know I thought
that was everyone complaining or being
sad about secondary infertility I'm like
you have one being
so greedy so then I felt guilty about
that greed after I had Sonny like should
I just be happy with her and stop but
the truth is is that we want her to have
a sibling yes when you break a silence
on a subject like this it's always a
little bit scary but I'm curious to
learn what you heard from other women
after the the story came out and and
what are the benefits of sharing this
type of story just when I was in your
makeup room I was getting another
private message from a woman telling me
her story I get these stories on a daily
basis on all my social media platforms
and after I shared after I wrote the
Glamour op-ed I went to my bosses at New
York one and I said I am overwhelmed and
inundated by these stories we have to do
something so we organized a panel of
women to talk about miscarriage because
these women are looking for a venue to
talk about their feelings and like you
were saying to create a vocabulary
around the grief of it all was it easier
for you to talk about it because you are
pregnant with another baby coming up and
- yeah easier for you to step out there
in a very private and personal way
absolutely and I tell women that when
they come to me and they ask me
questions I always say listen it's so
much easier from where I sit to tell you
how to act and what I think is best for
you to do because look at me who's most
at risk Tara right basically can you say
yeah so we know 80% of these happen in
that first trimester and half of those
are due to genetic or chromosomal
abnormalities with the embryo which are
totally random events however one thing
that increases the risk of that is
advanced maternal age so when you're
over 35 so 20% risk of miscarriage
around 35 that jumps to about 40% when
you're 40 previous early pregnancy loss
can be a risk factor there's certain
medical conditions thyroid conditions
PCOS clotting disorders obesity and even
uterine conditions that can raise risk
all right guys well there was silence
around it but I'm glad that that's it's
ending and we brought that to this table
thank you both very much